and the media of course part of the
liberal establishment too and totally in
bed with the
with the democrats there was a very
important headline in newsweek i don't
know if you caught it
you know because i i try to read all the
most important news
newsweek is reporting quote joe biden
playing as luigi wins in mario kart race
against
granddaughter at camp david
man i was worried there for a second i
was worried the president might lose or
he might he might play as bowser or
something my play is
peach i don't know i haven't played
mario in quite a while this is the
article seriously i'm not making this
it's not the babylon b
article says how did joe biden relax
during his first president day weekend
as president by playing mario kart with
his family during his weekend retreat at
camp david biden and his granddaughter
naomi that's one of the grandchildren
that he's willing to acknowledge
there are other grandchildren of course
that joe biden refuses to acknowledge
in a very cruel and callous way still
refuses to acknowledge them
all these all these months and years
later but naomi she's one of the nice
grandchildren that he will acknowledge
played the racing video game and he won
naomi shared a video to instagram that
showed biden competing against her
on the arcade gpdx machines complete
with chairs and steering wheels
biden sat on the right is luigi and
naomi is princess peach on the left okay
i can't i can't read this anymore
imagine imagine what the media would
have written about trump
idiot trump who is lazy and
incompetent at his job wastes time
playing video games
with nazi grandchildren right it's like
i think very that'd be like a soft
headline
in the trump administration but this is
just the only reason i bring it up it's
kind of funny
is is to show you there will not be
journalism
the closest thing you're going to get to
any reporting is
from the right you're going to get some
conservative outlets where we're still
permitted i guess to broadcast every now
and again
but of course we're siloed and no matter
how robust the conservative ecosystem is
daily wire does pretty well
but daily wire is one source right
compared to
nbc abc cbs cnn so so you
you could read a headline that says
daily wire does well on facebook you
know we
we're a big publisher on facebook where
we do you know bench bureau show
one of the top podcasts in the world
we're catching up we're getting close
but still you know
the michael knowles show big show andrew
clavin show what you know this
matt wall show these are bigger shows
that's one outlet
compared to every newspaper basically
every tv network basically increasingly
including the so-called right-wing ones
every a major
radio outlet not am talk radio that's
still held by conservatives but the rest
one
much of the digital space all the tech
platforms which are increasingly people
sources of news
it's all dominated by the left and
you're not going to get any reporting
here's what you're going to get from cnn
another bit of breaking news i don't
this is shocking stuff
obviously of great national import so if
you're driving right now please pull
over your car
headline from cnn inside the new
president's routine
oval office fires and early bedtimes
joe biden goes to bed early not exactly
a man bites dog story
it's that's actually what they're
reporting they say quote
unlike his most recent predecessors
night owls who spent the dark hours
reading briefing materials
president obama or watching television
president trump can you believe that
even you know donald trump even his
worst critics
should be able to admit that guy's a
workaholic he's working all the time
he's
infamous for doing so but they say no
you know obama's reading and doing
important work at night
and uh donald trump you know he's just
up watching tv
like some idiot at night by the way what
what was
bill clinton doing in those early
morning hours cnn seems to have left
that out neither here nor there
we'll talk about it another time but
what cnn wants to report is unlike
trump and obama who stayed up late biden
is more of an early to bed type gee you
don't say
our our senile president is a
is going to bed a little early i'm
shocked to hear it if you enjoyed that
video be sure to hit the subscribe
button so
everyone wading through the wasteland of
youtube knows that we've got the
absolute top content
out there
[Music]
you